dire new benchmarks in the nation's
battle with the coronavirus there are
now more than 12
million infections in the united states
that's one million more new cases
since sunday there were more than 195
thousand
infections reported on friday alone
hospitalizations topped 82
000 and there have now been 1600 deaths
a day since sunday in california where
10 p.m curfews to help flatten the curve
begin tonight
drivers waited in long lines at dodger
stadium in los angeles for drive-through
testing on friday
this as pfizer the pharmaceutical
company formally requested emergency
authorization for
use of its coronavirus vaccine tom
hansen begins our coverage here in new
york this morning tom good morning
good morning dana well across the
country more and more city states and
counties are clamping down
issuing restrictions on restaurants and
gyms and implementing those late night
curfews
all in a desperate effort to curb the
surge of the coronavirus
for the estimated 50 million
thanksgiving travelers who are doing so
against recommendations from the centers
for disease control and prevention
giving thanks may also mean taking big
risks
anyone at higher risk of disease we're
encouraging you please
it's better not to go don't take a
chance right now in state after state
there's alarm it's rather shocking but
about one in every 49 coloradans are
contagious with this
in oregon the daily number of cases
hospitalizations and deaths set records
in hard hit north dakota a state with
one of the highest daily death rates per
capita in the world
60 air force nurses have been dispatched
to help relieve
exhausted health care workers and
everywhere front line fighters who work
with covid patients
are testifying to their own trauma at
the end of the day i would go home and
go straight to the shower
part of this was to protect myself and
my family
but the other part was so i could go cry
in the shower and finally release for
the day
i have never seen so much death
and so much sickness in the past two
weeks
than i have in my entire 10 years in
healthcare
with hospitals overwhelmed by covid
patients newark new jersey officials
asked residents to stay home for 10 days
in philadelphia restaurants are
restricted again
this time to outdoor dining no more than
four per table
and california has imposed an overnight
10 pm to 5 a.m stay home
order the push to control cases is now a
race against time
the promise of a vaccine moved closer to
reality this week
pfizer applied for emergency vaccine
approval that could mean health care
professionals can start being vaccinated
in december and there's even hope 50
million doses will be available by the
end
of the year and more on that vaccine cbs
news has learned of a massive
effort underway to get scientific review
for the vaccine
which is essential in ensuring that it's
truly safe
michelle it can't come quick enough tom
thank you